we use basis for Exponential's as well
right
do you remember I'm just going to write
something parallel to this if I wrote
this which you're quite familiar with
back from like year seven days for you
do the indices right here you say oh I'm
multiplying numbers with the same base
so that means you do what to the powers
you add them when you multiply numbers
of the same base you add the powers well
remember I said to you logs are like
exponential equations but from another
perspective actually the other
perspective is from Reverse okay so here
when you add logs you multiply this
number when you multiply Exponential's
you add this multiplying because adding
adding becomes multiplying so because
you're looking from two different
perspectives you get these two different
results in fact this is some point let's
just write down so we get it straight in
their head when multiplying
Exponential's that's what these guys are
stuff with powers at the top so long as
they have the same base like this is 3
to power something and 3 the power
something else so long if they have the
same base we add powers but down here
it's in reverse because the same object
looked at from the other side it's like
a coin you've got a heads tail you've
got a tails head side a tail side I said
head tail do when you're looking at
opposite sides instead of going from
multiplying to adding here we're adding
and that turns into multiplying so when
adding not Exponential's but logs or
logarithms right to right logs just
consider it short up with adding logs
and again it's got to be with the same
base we multiply
the numbers inside the logs in this case
it was 525 in this case it was P and Q
adding two multiplying multiplying 2
adding okay now you say to get a sense
of okay everything I know about
Exponential's will help me with logs see
that index law over there there's
another index lot that goes with it but
it's for division instead of
multiplication here remember if I gave
you something like 3 sorry for this
wrote up soon 2 to the seventh and I
said divided by 2 cubed you're dividing
instead of multiplying so instead of
adding this is the opposite right what I
do I subtract I subtract 7 take away 3
okay so therefore dividing Exponential's
turns into subtraction third again
dividing Exponential's turns into
subtraction so what kind of Lord Lord do
you think would go with that being that
we're sort of reversing everything yeah
very good in case you didn't catch that
it's just like this but in Reverse if
you are subtracting Logs with the same
base then we divide the numbers inside
the logs okay so what would that look
like I need a bit more space here
against I'm going to put this under the
heading of laws if instead of adding
these logs I am subtracting you I'm not
going to multiply I'll do the opposite I
will divide let's use P divided by Q
okay yeah please keep in mind this is
what I try and get across to you it's a
bit slower but I hope it works better
these things here are not just written
down edged in stone because someone said
so they just flow logically from what
you already know to be true
and they're just making a shortcut of
all of these operations rather doing
them all from scratch can we think of an
example with numbers that would work
with this how could we write bless you
and a log equation that goes say with
this guy over here what would be
equivalent you know anything log 5 of
what say this would be okay you're sure
we're thinking about subtraction right
log base 5 of 5 so in this case what we
expect is for this to be log base 5 of
what am I going to do to these numbers
divide so 125 divided by 5 that's 25
right ok
now let's actually look at what the
numbers for each of these things is you
already know this is 3 and this is 1 is
this is log base 5 of 25 is that - it is
it works ok